am i a quitter I recently got asked a
really super important question by one
of my youtube fans love you guys Rho
heat who asked what if I find something
and then I realized it's not my passion
am I being a quitter this is a fantastic
question because you have to do a lot of
soul-searching as a person as an
entrepreneur and I believe the one thing
that that you hold core to you that
stays with you for the rest of your life
is your one word right that is your core
value who it is that you stand for you
make all your most important decisions
based off that everything else can
potentially change including the
passions that you have in life and there
are some much preneur to start a
business because they're running away
from my life right they're running away
from working at working for the man you
know having a job working set hours they
think they can make a lot of money doing
something they've seen something on TV
or heard their friends talk about it or
somebody's promised you to make lots of
money so you start a business and then
you get into the business you realize oh
my you know this is a lot of work and
you're not passionate about it and you
end up having to close it down that's a
lot of entrepreneurs there's also the
entrepreneurs who start off with the
right reasons you start off because
you're trying to make a difference in
the world you start off because you
really want to help people in some way
make their lives better you have a
passion for what you're doing but it's
actually fairly common for that passion
at some point to waver and to fall off
and you either have to find a different
way to stand a different way to pivot
your company or you have to close it
down and go do something else depending
on how much that passion is falling off
and so it's okay to quit at that point
you know when do you quit you quit when
you're not loving it anymore you quit
when you when you when it doesn't make
you come alive anymore it you quit when
you're not inspired or learning anymore
that's when you quit that's when you
should quit you don't quit just because
it gets hard okay you don't quit because
you don't have it you don't have enough
money you don't quit because you know
you're not getting market acceptance yet
it's gonna be hard but as long as you
love it as long as you're getting
energized by it as long as you still
want to make a difference in this world
then you have to keep going through all
the crap that's
to come at you but the thing that keeps
you going is your passion if you're not
passionate about anymore it's over you
have to quit you have to quit you got to
move on and do something else sell the
business give it to somebody else in the
company whatever it is you cannot do
great things if you're going to work
every day not loving your job not loving
the company that you started if you
don't love your business if you don't
love what you're doing you can't expect
anything great to happen and that
translates into your personal life to
imagine you're going to work every day
hating what you're doing you think
you're gonna be happy coming home and
that's most people's lives you have to
continue to follow what excites you
follow your passion follow your flow and
when that stops then you stop and do
something else and it's really scary
it's scary because you don't want to be
a quitter
right you don't want to look in the
mirror and see a quitter and you don't
want other people to think of you as a
quitter but you can't let those feelings
hold you back because that's gonna keep
you in place doing something that you
hate a personal story for me one of the
hardest things that I had that I really
struggled with was my divorce and and I
don't talk about it too much because
it's still you know it's painful but I
didn't want to quit I didn't want the
divorce to start with I felt it was
quitting and I don't I don't see myself
as a quitter you know when I set my mind
and doing something I go out and find
some way to accomplish it and I didn't
want to look in the mirror and see
someone who quit on something someone
that I committed to and I didn't want
other people to see me as a quitter - I
didn't want other people to see me as a
failure even though so many people get
divorced whatever it doesn't matter I
didn't want other people to see me as a
failure as a quitter but at the same
time you're in a relationship that
doesn't support you yeah you know you're
in a relationship that doesn't make you
happy and it started off great and there
was a lot of passion and then you know
do you want to come home to somebody who
doesn't make you happy anymore
do you want that to be the rest of your
life and so I went through and got
divorced and I'm much happier now and I
don't see that as being a quitter as a
definition of Who I am and so you're
gonna have to make those tough decisions
in your personal life and in your
business life as well
but what I know is if you are not doing
the things that you love to do if you
don't feel inspired in your day-to-day
life and in the actions that you're
taking if you're not taking inspired
action you're not going to be a happy
person and you're not going to
accomplish great things so it's okay to
quit but you only quit when you lose the
passion believe those are you watching
if you liked the video you want to see
more just like this you can subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon